[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLE BUNZEL: My dissertation’s title is
“The Escalation of Enmity: The Origins and
Evolution of Militant Wahhabism.”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLE BUNZEL: Wahhabism is an Islamic revivalist
movement that begins in the mid 18th century
in, what is today, Saudi Arabia.
It was a highly militant and aggressive and
exclusivist movement that deemed the majority
of the world's Muslims to be infidels.
BERNARD HAYKEL: He's incredibly imaginative,
resourceful, intrepid.
The topic that he is working on is not only
intellectually difficult to write about and
to understand-- it spans three centuries of
intellectual and political history-- but it's
also very difficult to get the primary sources,
to do the work.
COLE BUNZEL: A lot of it is luck, a lot of
it is persistence.
I spent more than two years trying to get
access to one manuscript, in Riyadh, in an
archive, which, eventually, I was able to
do.
Also, just spending time in cafes with ordinary
folks, you build contacts and eventually,
I met enough people who are from this northern
region in Saudi Arabia.
And they actually drove me there and opened
up the private libraries of the region for
me.
BERNARD HAYKEL: He just goes and he finds
like these shiny objects, all over the world,
that I had never thought existed.
And there are people who think, or who thought,
that they had seen everything.
And then all this stuff is unearthed by Cole.
COLE BUNZEL: Professor Haykel and I, we are
co-teaching a seminar for undergraduates that's
titled Jihadism in the Modern Middle East.
BERNARD HAYKEL: Bringing together a faculty
member with a graduate student to teach has
been really wonderful.
And also, the students can see in him someone
that they can aspire to be like.
They can attain the level of expertise and
scholarship that he has attained.
COLE BUNZEL: Professor Haykel has been a wonderful
adviser.
He's helped me in basically every dimension
of my studies, here at Princeton.
He's helped me learn Arabic better.
He's helped me understand Wahhabi theology
better.
He's helped me gain access to Saudi Arabia.
Basically, can't imagine being able to do
what I've done without my adviser.
[MUSIC PLAYING]